thank you very much this is my second
times under a game the purple summit it
was really good to be here and I can see
that the faces i-i've known before and I
hope they enjoy the session about we'll
talk a little bit about the awoken and
also some problems we can face that
during real world and all invite it was
an NG sound to talk about more a great
creation on the Final Fantasy 15 Pocket
Edition as a best practice so I'm
reading GPU driver team and also came to
AB Tech team in Samsung mobile division
so we'll start with the Balkan so let's
try this who already knew about pokken
many book and developers who are really
engaged with your Balkan project now the
usual thing so walking is not using the
book and publish it from 2016 February
from Cronus and multiple companies
really hard to offer to making that
happen in right on time
but the still we are saying the woken is
the future API or something it's mean is
not perfect yet maybe so because a
growing of importance of the gaming in
Android is really higher than and also
you can see that market and the business
is merging between a pc and mobile more
and more like new genre in mobile
and PvP games the what we've seen
similar with the MMORPG in APEC so that
the expectation from the users a little
bit different from because there are
different area or different a platform
like because these users coming from PC
and console they really care about that
fidelity of the game but in Android the
mobile devices is still in some
limitation because in the battery
technology is not enhanced a lot so it's
stuck on somewhere during recent over
ten years so there's still many Huddle's
to limited budget of the power and
performance so the new technology really
really required to overcome that so the
optimization itself is really important
than ever but you can imagine easily
about the traditional optimization is
just trade-off between the quality and
also performance if you want to
increasing more FPS then you just
dropping down your fatality of the game
but that that new users the expectation
is something like that even just five
inches obscures your mobile phone and
how we can overcome this what is the
advanced optimization what is the
fundamental solution for that you will
be the better quality but there's better
performance we think the balkan is one
of the answer am i right I'm not sure
but I am sure several things even Balkan
is not so perfect but still work and
because many people already knew about
the what pokken is so I just run through
this really quickly
walking but advantage is because that is
cross-platform support and lightweight
predictable explicit control and there's
a bunch of great tools to help you to
optimize your game that is packed it's
not I'm not lying
and yes there's a low overhead you can
you can add more tacos than GL yes it's
not means you can cover 3000 roll call
for your game but it's maybe a three or
four times more drakul you can cover
with a book and than GL es so I heard
some times but our partner game
developers just mentioned my game is
really slow even with a new Galaxy S 9 I
saw that at two thousand roubles it's
not so they capable to be covered on the
device even it up to date model but it's
still that is capable to do more draw
holes where the wall content areas and
more controllability you can have is not
mean that you can resolving any issues
with that but you have the more margin
or way of the control thing is a fitted
into your content to better performance
it's not just they command buffer
command before submission but also the
other things too like ground allocation
memory binding the memory copying memory
and also the merging the render passes
and making surpasses is grouping that
passes into the one or split the timings
so on and the other various of way of
optimization you can help you can make
more better management of the resources
and can have more way of reusing your
resources you've used before then that
means there's
more possibilities you can optimize or
improve things better than GL yes
because GL yes there's not many things
you can do also you can have a
implementation the bulk and you can see
many ways even that is not giving you
that twice or a third time better
performance but you can find that a
small amount of the improvement that
also can give you more capability to the
things more you can show to people make
differences so yes we can see that twice
or a third time better performance FPS
with the simple demo we made some cool
demo Protista for our s7 unpack but that
is just demo and samples or showing off
the real word is is not that simple like
this it's more complicated than and
could be think you the balkan is a kind
of the magic and just click the button
and everything is going better but real
work that is not so you have to do
something and sometimes you cannot get
any benefit of that so means the token
is advanced technology can deliver you
more optimizing your contents with a
better quality and better performance at
the same time but it could not be the
solution for your contents sometimes so
during our collaboration with
experiences with our game partner that
partner game companies under our new not
give you this problem with 2016 our game
developer support program yells game
doubt we struggle with many issues and
problems so now I will talk about the
real-world problems we run from those
experiences yes the Balkan has have has
some advantages but it's not so simple
and is not so all solution for all cases
if you do the just pouring API from GL
yes to Balkan and that implementation is
proper and you can have a quite big
improvement in CPU that is true but it's
not giving you sometimes it's better
performance because it sometimes is
bounded by GPU fully or your
implementation is not wrong but it's not
well fitted into a certain game as
certain GPU architecture so the GPU is
the real problem yes partly there's some
part of that that GPU driver is the
issues because the quality is not enough
sometimes the game develop from the
console and PC they complain about that
the mobile GPU is not enough performance
yes because that mobile GPU is running
on just less than 10 watt power but your
G pores is running with over a 100 watt
or something is the 10 times bigger
power budget they can use so the mobile
GPU is is you can you have to bury only
those two quality and performance issues
is just fundamental thing about that
quality we are now try to improve more
than that with the Google and also the
other GPU vendors but still there's
something remained so the GPU is not the
real problems partly because you are
wrong targeting the power budget and
performance target
so is bounded by fully GPU because you
overloaded fidelity of the graphics to
overwork your GPU a lot then that will
not give you any benefit and also your
implementation is not well fitted with
certain GPU architect that is also one
of the problem so you have to figure out
with some optimization or better policy
to target the power budget and
performance target so for chasing that
topic the developers really need to have
some way of optimizing and analysis or
something so the simplest way is just
delivering better game engine including
all the solution but as you know the
unity and ue4 is not that level yet I'm
sorry and also we have to bring more
better tooling to understand more to
deliver way of the way that deliver the
game developers to understand more about
their games running on a device inside
and also do they bring more a better way
of interacting the OEM and GPU bandit to
share your feedback is you can you can
you can share about similar things what
I'm now talking about and that morning
times former session also Google guys
know talking about
so the pended channel is there and also
you have a google channel but the
problem is when you found that a GPU
driver box then whatever you connect
contact with dependent work or a cool
but it not give you fix your problem
because the driver fixes should be
shipping into the real product into the
market so we we have to
about that kind of thing but it's
usually the game debug doesn't have any
channel to contacting where the OEM that
is really hurt the situation in around
or they ecosystem so we are now
announcing the game doubt and you can
contact with the game depth as something
that come anytime you want and the last
one is the better guidance about power
budget and performance type I want to
leave it talk more about this power
budget so my personal opinion you have
to avoid the GPU bounding situation at
all with your content
so there's the three bounding types
this one is CPU bounding and second is
this GPU bounding and the best case is a
non-bonding situation so if you have a
three different type of situation with
your GL es pill and after bulk and port
you can have some benefit with the
balkan with the CPU bonding and normal
situation but you cannot see any benefit
with bulk and port which is GPU bounding
you can easily see after bulk and port
the CPU broad is decreased and then GPU
rode it increased because of a PS
increasing but with the GPU bounding
situation just a CPU drop but because
GPU is are already in the 100% busy so
there is no way of increasing more FPS
so the good design policy about the
power budget is so making a left french
road with your former device target and
adjusting that road with
the other quality leveling and also to
perform a different performance target
adjustment for the lower load for the
old devices set and the high load for
the latest device set and also you can
consider carefully this budget is also
you have to consider a throttling
situation and about performance target
you sometimes have to design your
performance target with resolution and
fps so HD 30 frames per second is there
then you can easily imagine that
increasing your resolution to the full
HD will go up the GPU a lot but with
post fps and resolution double then you
can expect easily to imagine that the
right side of the picture the GPU will
be the quadruple and CPU will be double
is a quiet higher increasing road for
your post GPU and CPU and quality the
leveling is a little bit more
complicated you can you can tune your
quality level for the effect or that
geometry and characters details and also
resolution of texture but it also can
make a side effect to give a heard that
memory bandwidth and so on so you have
to really carefully design that and need
more better understanding about the GPU
and system inside
so with this guidance I am sure during
this session the the policy and design
performance target and also the power
budget we use this policy for our
partners and ninety percent our partner
games get benefit is comes from the 15
percent to around it twice better and
that one remained problem about this
guidance because you usually do not have
any way to measuring the road itself
easily with the other tools and also
just in the device so we are on the
developing our internal to the shipping
with the galaxy there's a call the GPU
watch that will give you more better
understanding and the way of measuring
to load within the budget target of that
device oh one more thing is the plan to
be integrated into the developer option
I cannot say I cannot promising that the
one that will be shipping but that will
be shipping it someday soon and poor
poor better understanding about the tool
we are working with the Google and other
GPU vendors like the gap it and perfeito
render dog and the bandit tools likes
metro and provider Molly graphic tipper
and des pipe streamline we are really
hard effort to support them and improve
that and shipping with more better
support a tool a summary is we have
tried to steer all concentric word in
the industry of game gaming in Android
mobile but it's really not that simple
and so we continue a heavy effort to
bring our quality of the driver and
better tooling also will deliver
and clear guidance of the power budget
and perform target really hope to have
your feedback please contact game Davis
on comm for any questions or feedback
and I want to introduce ethos and ng
sound to talk about the Final Fantasy 15
Pocket Edition as the best practices of
game broken game optimization okay hello
my name is Koh Saito and I am a producer
at luminous productions
one of the screening studio first please
take a look at this short video
[Music]
okay so what you just saw was our latest
Final Fantasy 15 efforts we call it
final fantasy 15 universe it is a
universe that has a console game ff15 at
its base it continues to transcend all
platforms and expand its reach
throughout the globe two years ago Final
Fantasy 15 which was a reason for home
game console become a huge hit sitting
over 6.5 millions units worldwide now
the mobile version of Final Fantasy 15
comes to smart phone and tablet with the
Final Fantasy 15 Pocket Edition that we
would like to showcase for you all today
so please watch this short video
[Music]
we think can't forget about hitching our
way there people were friendly outside
this thing and I couldn't so far on the
kindness of speech that be nice scan it
ready steady feast monkey grandma if
you're up to the challenge
how about it
[Music]
sorry we have some audio problem anyway
Final Fantasy 15 Pocket Edition
underwent Alicia's brutal optimization
process in order to bring Final Fantasy
15 to mobile devices the game has also
been route optimized and awesome game
graphics is just the start of it we
logically change the look of the game to
match our target users the game was
released in a series of episodes and by
the way galaxy played a huge role in its
development the game fully supported
decks and burka so now let's get the
lead programmer yoshimasa ng as
summertime studio to showcase the
activities that we engage in with
Samsung for Barca support
yes son good job
come up I'm estacin Oh sweetie oh no in
this I can him for translation
hello my name is Angie I'm a city of
summertime studio it's a developer Final
Fantasy 15 Pocket Edition today what
espera a final fantasy 15
okay traditional vodka vodka I know I
know psychic can fit a joke I say yeah
I'd like to talk about optimization
Eugene Baraka of Final Fantasy 15 Pocket
Edition Final Fantasy 15 Pocket Edition
no oh Konami you connected out of bed
with one of the major point of Final
Fantasy 15 graphics wise it's you know
Otto style Final Fantasy 15 was the
title case was at Attica quit there any
mo kawaranai up to tie drama - master
while being faithful to the world of
Final Fantasy we aimed satisfied which
it's an icon and the friendliest
photorealistic one come on you're
picking on auto stereo gaming i decided
i dont dust emmanuel
it gr you never Knight animetro
demoknight atarashi could conjure ganga
still the stuff in order to bring this
out of style to appear wider the answer
we needed to create a new
Naughton anime style but to produce
ambience observe vigil
using new style so-called a cook on the
hill games it's against the Tamiya
Unity Technologies shuttle homonymous
whole course at the starcade cup yes -
Tecna
post-processing with Doc oh don't use
ricotta nickimja must to achieve the
call we have we discussed with unity
technology and eventually we we decided
to adapt post-processing stock of unity
post-processing the stacker Samantha
mana postal hecto a student okay notice
it over she a huge type kokum creamiest
sighted catch the ethically through
postal surely open I do you Deena tragic
you notice the post processing stock is
limited new futures that can merge
multiple post effect into one and quite
optimal to produce quite great graphics
effect game natural cappuccino cattle
Tony comical 4000 CC danke we know
grotty graphics called Jesus master by
adapting post-processing stock we were
able to achieve better graphics quality
and that we were able to tune each of
the scenes in the game about Capucine
academic gave me pretty more significant
auto sistema not only did we do clintus
cutscenes but also during the gameplay
we have churned performance using using
positive post processing stock the
technique of acoustic screen so to
acutally
quality a screenshot which shows the
difference of quality is here we got to
say my status taken a screenshot to this
so the screenshots that had comparable
before-and-afters using suppose the
processing stacks near explain styrene
show artist of a kamikaze the glutamine
character a high piano most acute angle
a huge a new proposed master for each of
the scenes we are able to choose
graphics parameter and we are able to
achieve
qualities that our artists were aiming
to commercial seochon Ottoman Uwe
collaborating with in effect co-state
kappa nutiva circus in de ma chambre we
need to know more trick Odysseus team we
used color grading through
and a full-screen anti-aliasing and for
some scenes we adapted a depth of field
motion bra and pigeon ate em and so on
we use the multiple positive post
effects hi discussed a career that
cannot postpone sister here Seto put a
monkey Nassif comin outta me under
Thomas it was a facility to a big piece
to estimate this Melba MIMO economist
but as you can imagine those kind of
post-processing would take a lot of GPU
Road and sometimes it went to below 20
frames per second on some Android
devices
Konoe quality you insist on mama hundred
be a physio medicine you are a bona fide
it reversed realistic our goal was to
achieve sati frame per second so that we
needed to do some kind of optimization
to achieve the goal with graphics
quality come Kai I'm very determined to
make inside this cosmetic unitary
screenings no meanness tomahto Sampson
game day with Jim you know me
automatically repeated a key support
Ocampo
this issue data key master so we work
together with Samsung graphics
optimization team and the screenings as
well to achieve so cool it's time to
jump to johannes de details yes I should
taking you up okay Yong Chi a go cake
would you stand it anymore even a guy
can you attacked a copy repeated a
chemistry our initial expectations just
having a short-term camp but eventually
it became in a total of 53 days support
camp commute empanadas guilty you know
angie beavin team added to karate Vulcan
was just a graphic showing off ID cause
of the miracle dog economists are why
does the camp we optimized unity and
inside and we are able to achieve goal
using Birkin
mother unity D tau F if 15 phuket
tuition we can you customize this data
may what accommodated OC providing local
I'm a star
at first we be periods
imitating Falcon we build its unity
engine using Park on settings so no kike
I'm not even the pursue Suzuka tissue
steeped in Kolkata Linda passed no
Kyoukai medica assumed authority
rhetoric economists are that's profiling
result we've hands that monitor pool
render pass was being used which can be
combined into one been depressed come on
I will be she was a killer to me then
going to render pass no Jo chick she on
Tony still not to get a kike Okinawan
Anka semester so we added a quick called
two chicks in the past status and much
multiple render passes into one bus
every fifteen pork a tradition they were
almost ID caserita NGO
a unity editor directly under the
platform then I grab you open at Lima in
Final Fantasy 15 pocket Asian we are
using now unity editor with this
optimization comma custom we did Daniel
if Tim poke a tradition okay hot Sione
edit our class which now in cases the
diarrhea the exenatide is Orchestra
Bunga from a latina this version of
unity editor is having other
optimization or bug fixes like not to
crush the editor or some optimization to
make tech support person again Eva sorry
to start the campus neox assisted to you
a projection screen on Monday demo at
investor a to Sydney and Cody Chile
Costa with him Cody guilty or not I'm a
scientist very much it's a little crush
that I mentioned that was originating
from our core design but it was had in
our side to work on this issue so we
shown we chose to
observable canonical unity editor sila
Kickapoo State Bar economy pou destiny
chiefly mini CPU got capita Volquez
Ganga Yamuna Bo Cara zucchini Bhutto
Yokohama knows you can attach sorry
master by performing the optimizations
we were able to achieve CP road from 60
millisecond to 90 minute second using
balkan opengl es de dos tomochka cuesta
Minato do you have to be a single mother
with condita Ginga Sandra periodic IT
industry math in comparison to OpenGL
version OpenGL version was 18 frames per
second and overcome her jaw was broken
body is sati frame per second what you
don't submit in all cases it co suit hua
qian i this got 15 pocket position the
what what what every apne recited can
you tip hormones no chi cheng at the
keymaster
so that in our case in our case of Final
Fantasy 15 pocket duration optimization
Boracay adapting Baraka API worked
pretty well how can you mo game isn't
able to take in providing with school
geometry from its Kay Kyser schema we
did some other optimization not limited
to work ID so but we did optimizations
our game encoder itself as well cool
demo something game David Seaman Amir
salmon Ibuki repeated lucky you reopen
ultimately kai taking those of the
ellipticity master samsung game dev team
also contributed this part as well para
que piensa que la quinta de mar de pasto
solicit a mosaic on a GPU no silifke mo
k diastema
for the pasta effect post-processing
as well we did optimization of code
itself yes the unity Kapil is I think as
opposed to Scylla post-processing stuck
to a bit nominally a game liner graphics
no option to state center community ma
that version optimized for
stuff post-processing this is this one
it's different from unity the
post-processing stunk and it was it's
selectable option means again process
significantly mo aside Akane
Scott's a ghost and Ezra a quality Oh
Lucy mode use Institute a mini coop it
was horrific Oh cut some more money
someone must you three pony give me
master we are also keeping post
processing stock option as is because it
can produce better graphics quality so
that mean you do cannot have much the
come on a committee with cushy black
liquid a as a video it should if cocaine
stop of perfect or near a semester and
we also had its lighter rendering option
to achieve a better performance in wider
variety of devices guy no Saddam o ke
samne you did this to me narsimha we did
optimizations a shader code as well
Tatiana's hydration of the tennis team
against certain disabilities in a tiny
Rio Negro fish must also we added a
capfuls a much mum about particles
yes teens again now can you incite if
Gaddafi do not cool in although you
cannot ask you another given a cute
Austin's ID Chaya Venice youth in its
kaimana MIDI Antonio cannot hide any
Cokie repeated a key master and are not
limited to the optimization some son dev
team contributed to fix some issues in
such game called and all the time
optimizations well so we are very
thankful thankful to them Konoha Chilean
I know they have a severe Christmas they
did tons of contributions but we cannot
risk all of the same here social
thinking if you fifteen Phuket division
wa boku no taiyou some other monocyte it
can you take internationally well if he
is very near by the entire hit Institute
oh yeah could you FPS cause you're
smashed up it's a bit Saratov of
optimization in average we
able touchy increase of 10 frames per
second in average and that maximum frame
rate can doubled so Luca postal
processing stucco's your state under the
Thomas they will hit quality oh yeah a
report on it ago semester so that we
successfully adapt post processing stock
and as a advanced feature to achieve a
better quality company to the community
screams no - Amato Final Fantasy 15
pocket tradition to you cruelty
authenticity - state I to know he has
nice avocado crema Pima I'm very proud
of the result which was able to achieve
with contribute which coocking with
Samsung and display annex development
team something game dev team in a minute
Imani Mugabe repeated Aki Final Fantasy
15 ok traditional graphic tapa humans
new game coyote honky Aguirre quadratic
in monster we are able to achieve better
quality and performance at the same time
using baroque and as other optimization
techniques so steve journeyman amino
acid k2 nana master onyx filled with
tickets at american sistema this has
been great opportunity for us to achieve
better quality and develop greater games
many songs to people to be to contribute
you can imagine what it really got all
day my stuff
thank you very much
[Applause]